the best way to think about the bullet
Journal method as a whole is as your
laboratory for life it's a blank page
essentially and you create whatever game
or goal you want to play every day
what's beautiful about this methodology
it's powered by your intention what is
it that you're curious about what do you
want more of what do you want less of
and then you start finding the tools
that's help support that I provide a
bunch of different tools to help you
organize your thoughts and different
rituals to help you check in but a big
part of this is about self-discovery for
me the thing that was so challenging
growing up is people kept shoving
productivity systems down my throat like
this will make you smart this will make
you more productive but none of them
work the way that my mind worked and a
big part about bullet journaling is
discovering what works for you and that
changes all the time which is what makes
it relevant over time right like when
you're working nine to five it's one
thing when you become a parent it's
another thing when you start traveling
it's another thing when you're reading
this it becomes a different thing you
know and that's what keeps on making it
relevant